in seinen lieblingsfilm flattert eine
menschengroße fledermaus durch die
gegend und im fernsehen punkte am
liebsten dragon ball z
wann wird der mann endlich erwachsen
diese und viele andere gemeinde fragen
jetzt in frage ob mixa wir kommen zu den
hier das fragen motto du kennst dich aus
du hast weiß was jetzt passiert ungefähr
ok dann würde ich sagen greift zu
welchem an welche noch mal die roten
sind gemein
fangen wir eine gute aber eigentlich
immer alle gut bei euch gelesen na ja
das kann man so sagen also das ist immer
die leute wenn sie sind durchstanden
haben meine macht die waren harmlos aber
ich habe auch schon leute gehabt die
sind die jersey ist mir einmal fast an
die gurgel gegangen
wirklich ja ja der war echt ein bisschen
angenähert österreichern also die frage
ist was passiert wie kommt es dass du so
gut aus dass also eigentlich ist es denn
der gemeine frage weil von sich
selbstlos auf lob auszusprechen ist
immer sehr unsympathisch aber ich glaube
das sind die gene meiner mama okay man
das jetzt notarzt ich mache mir jetzt
bewusst mal gucken was passiert mit dem
österreicher ok wann ist es endlich zeit
der musik an den nagel zu hängen und mit
etwas ordentlichen anzufassen
ja man etwas ordentliches kann man
natürlich immer so definieren wie man es
möchte und wann es zeit ist die musik an
den nagel zu hängen glaube ich sollte
musiker dann erkennen wenn er einfach
nicht mehr erfolgreich ist
du stehst auf dragon ball und batman
wann wirst du erwachsen also wie man
gesehen hat habe ich mich eigentlich
sehr schlecht darin geschlagen
also muss ich meine wer weiß mehr wenn
es noch nicht erschienen ist dann abend
es hier nach dem wagen
es wird spannend also ich denke dass es
auf jeden fall nichts mit
erwachsenwerden sein zutun damit zu tun
hat weil ganz einfach ich der meinung
bin dass die ganzen neuen batman finden
wir auch nichts für kinder sind so nett
und dragonball und ehrlich ich sehe aus
wie der schwarz gruppe g t das ist eine
beschissene frage der sinn dieses spiel
so etwa wieder eine um mein ego
aufzufrischen
das klingt mit den wagen sehr gut ja ja
ja absolut
seit 2008 kann jedes ein album wie
schaffst du was sich einfach mal
zwischendurch eine gesunde pause nehmen
und dann auch wirklich gewollt an der
neues album rein gehen ohne den
hintergedanken zu haben es tun zu müssen
weil man sonst nicht über die runden
kommt so gibt es okay das heißt man muss
leben in rhythmus im leben haben aus
entspannung anspannung muss glaube ich
die den weg finden um auch irgendwie
abschalten zu können von dem ganzen um
dann mit neuer kraft zurück zukunft wenn
man das gefunden hat dann ist es glaube
ich auch nicht so schwierig ist deine
musik zu schlecht oder warum hatte sony
noch nie einen top ten erfolge in
deutschland ich meine das ist glaube ich
eine sehr gute frage eigentlich gar
keine böse weil es in den letzten jahren
irgendwie so geworden ist dass fans ich
glaube ich mit den charts viel mehr
beschäftigen als wir mit der musik und
auch daran messen ob die musik gut oder
schlecht ist
ich glaube genau der gedanke sollte euch
ganz schnell aus dem kopf gehen und wir
werden auch sehen wo das neue album von
jetzt also das heißt wenn ich jetzt in
dem fall der mauer gestellt hat sollte
ich top ten der musiker supergut zu
rechnen
okay du hast du schon eine gewisse
ahnung
natürlich nicht aber sagt er es ist
schwer
manchester und sonst was kann also ich
habe mir sehr sehr harte woche und ich
wünsche es mir und bis jetzt gingen
sehr viele meiner wünsche erfüllen mal
gucken was passiert so etwas um sie
steht das wünschte sich erfüllen ich
weiß daran glauben und wir auf holz
klopfen oder wenn man holz klopfen und
ich habe noch angewöhnt gott darum zu
bitten weil man geld dann immer nur dann
gut wenn man sich an dem etwas wünscht
und nicht zu ihm spricht wenn es einem
gut geht deswegen einfach nur sehr hart
daran arbeiten uns uns sehr viel dran
glauben wäre okay sozusagen rief er ihn
schon der wille versetzt berge aber man
muss auch was getan haben so jetzt zur
letzten frage du unterstellst dich durch
einen rap klar von anderen rappern wie
hast du diese einzigartigkeit indirekt
also ich glaube einzigartiges ist
trotzdem nicht was ich tue und ich lasse
mich natürlich auch sehr gern von
anderen künstlern was jetzt auch nicht
rapper sein menschen inspirieren und ich
glaube einfach nur einen kleinen vorteil
den ich vielleicht fliehen weil man in
deutschland gegenüber hab ist dass ich
auch prinzipiell für viele richtungen
der musik offen bin und es mir wirklich
auch gerne anhören das analysieren und
dann versucht für mich einfach die dinge
herauszufinden die mir gefallen und das
film auf meine art und weise umzusetzen
und wenn ich irgendwie festgefahren
einen film seit jahren schieben möchte
weil er gut funktioniert und dass meine
fans nicht wie man sieht schon also ich
hab meine fans kontinuierlich zur von
album zu album gesteigert und auch die
verkäufe haben sich immer mehr
gesteigert und sei nicht immer ein
zeichen dafür dass man alles richtig gut
vielen dank lustig auch das fragen mit
den 257 sie endlich offiziell erklären
warum sie kiz nicht nachmachen
da gibts wohl den einen oder anderen der
ihnen das unterstellt unterstellungen ja
immer in fragen lotto und gemeine vor
allen dingen auch bei cora die sich dazu
genötigt fühlt zu erklären wie man durch
pizza lebensfreude erlangt also wenn ihr
das unbedingt erfahren wollt und nicht
mehr ohne lebensfreude durch pizza
überleben könnte dann müsst ihr dieses
video unbedingt ansehen ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran